when the jaguars announced on tuesday
that they will be playing two games in
london in 2020 on a back-to-back basis
my first thought was home game for one
road game for the other oh no
it's a pair of home games 25
of the homes scheduled will be played
not in jacksonville but in london and
this is something that i think we've all
kind of suspected could happen and maybe
at some point it's going to be like the
old county stadium in milwaukee lambeau
field split the packers did for all
those years
but i i was i was shocked that the
jaguars are making that move
from seven and one
to six and two because it invites
speculation as to when it's going to be
five and three or four and four peter
your thoughts
two thoughts mike first of all uh not
that this is going to be anything that
anybody is against but eventually when
the nfl starts playing either three or
two preseason games
that will take
say once every other year if they
continue to do this a home game away in
august
so what it means is that now you know
really theoretically
that the jaguars will be going will be
not home
nine or ten times a year they're going
to be home maybe seven times a year
that's the first thing i thought i mean
the second thing is
look shad khan when he bought this team
and when the nfl started making noise
about london whatever this was five six
seven years ago
when all this happened there was no
question that he had london in his
sights
they want to be the nfl's team in london
and all this does is it gives them more
of a reason to have a foothold
permanently in london whether they end
up moving there or not they've already
got a foothold mic because they play
their games at wembley or they have
rather than at the nfl's new stadium in
tottenham so for those who don't care
about that just just understand that
that is a very big deal because they're
not siding with the nfl everybody has
thought that the nfl when they moved to
london
will play at this beautiful football
palace at you know in tottenham you know
where the tottenham hotspur play but
instead they've stayed at wembley they
want to have their own foothold their
own
footprint in london so to me
do you remember mike a long time ago
when al michaels said hey the nfl's
gonna have two teams in london and
everybody laughed
l.a i think
yeah in
l.a sorry about that and i think right
now
the nfl really
eventually i don't know when 15 years
maybe i don't know is gonna have two
teams in london well i do think it's
cool that jacksonville is trying to
create a little culture there in london
i do and like to peter's point about the
wembley stadium yeah i mean i think
that's exactly they're trying to kind of
make that like their home away from home
to a degree and hope that they can
create a you know a culture of jaguars
fan base in london and okay i got no
problem with it you know i don't you
know the jags yes they're one of the
newer franchises in our league we know
that and hey i mean economically it
makes sense for shotgun and and the
jaguars too i mean come on the jaguars
games we watch them yeah the stadium's
full it's fake full come on there's
tarps over like five ten thousand seats
uh every game so
you know i understand this type of move
and all that now to say that it's going
to happen full-time all right that's
where you know i just i don't know how
that can happen that's that's my only
thing i can see them maybe splitting
even down the future more home games you
know with london or something like that
but i just know me as if i was a veteran
nfl football player and they told me
damn hey you got to go to london and do
that and you know your team's going to
be playing over there you tell me i'm
gonna move my kids figure out you know
the the the cash swap out what the hell
they got over there the pound the dollar
all those things move my kids to a
school that's gonna be a completely
different system those things to me i
just don't know how the nfl can make
that work but i'm in favor for
jacksonville doing this more than one
game i think it's actually kind of cool
there are so many logistical issues that
relate to moving a team to london you
mentioned exchange rate tax rate the
road trip which for many teams is leave
saturday back sunday night you're going
to be gone for three weeks at a time
because when you cross the pond you're
going to stay there for multiple home
games before you come back or road games
before you come back for multiple home
games but here's the bottom line it is
the bottom line it's about money the
jaguars make more per game in london
than they make in jacksonville and i say
this all the time when it comes down to
stadiums you put stadiums where the
money and the people are you put teams
where the money and the people are and
there's more money in people in london
than there is in jacksonville and
there's going to be another city where
as the stadium reaches the end of its
useful life and we hear all this talk
about how committed ownership is to
staying until they're not right and i
think you're right peter i think the
jaguars become the guinea pigs to work
out all the kinks in london and as
another team sees hey you know what that
works
you may have that second team you've got
the two stadiums you get the two teams
natural rivalry it makes a ton of sense
and i was told a couple of years ago
that
if and when shot khan wants to move the
team there full-time he will have
support from membership they will vote
in favor of it anytime he wants to move
he will get the approval to move
all right well can i just say one thing
here uh just one thing yes yeah just
well to me like i mean you know isn't
jacksonville
you know spending 500 million dollars to
make their own little patriot place
outside of like so that it doesn't look
like he's trying to do anything here
recent in the recent future right aren't
they trying to build something there
close to their stadium to get more of an
environment around the stadium a little
bit in like new england maybe i'm wrong
but i also thought maybe that was part
of the reason they picked two games too
they think they have construction heavy
construction during those weeks and
that's why they wanted to move i don't
know but i i just wondered that sorry
well no yeah and you're right i'm a
question
go ahead peter
no listen here's the biggest question
okay about
not mike you you talk about logistics
let's say one thing about logistics you
know this has been this has been told to
me that if an nfl team when an nfl team
moves to london that they're gonna have
two options
that the nfl could say to them look
you're gonna have two
17-day trips to london during the season
and one nine-day trip to london during
the season in other words they're going
to be over there for three weeks at a
time
then back in the u.s for two or three
weeks and then over there for three back
and then over for two
or in some in some way so this is not
absolutely going to be a situation where
the team will move lock stock and barrel
with everything to london it's i mean
i don't know what it'll be but that
certainly is going to be one possibility
and then just about sort of the race to
london
you know one of the things that i've
always been told
is that london is going to be a part of
this new collective bargaining agreement
in some way
that you know there's going to be the
ability of an owner to move to london
but there's going to have to be some
concessions made to players in other
words
players are going to have to be able to
make a premium
if they play in london because it'll be
viewed as right as a hardship definitely
you know on the player and on his family
so
i believe that if it happens okay so the
salary cap this year is going to be
about 200 million bucks i believe that
it'll be something i'm gonna make this
up for a team that plays in london it'll
be like 2 30 because you're gonna have
to be able to pay players more money to
motivate them to play overseas
and see that's going to be the challenge
because any rules that are put in place
for one or more teams in london if those
teams end up being wildly successful the
argument's going to be from the other
teams hey you're doing too much you're
disrupting the competitive balance in a
way that unfairly benefits the london
teams by giving them more
salary cap space more draft picks or
whatever the case may be and you know
something occurred to me while you were
explaining that peter maybe the end
result isn't two teams in london on a
full-time basis maybe it is two teams
that split their schedule between their
american home stadium and one of the two
stadiums that are nfl ready in london
maybe that's the way that it goes down
but there's too much money to be made by
the nfl they want to do this and and
i'll tell you what
whatever they're doing in jacksonville
to make it like patriot place if shad
khan believes that one or two other
teams are ready to move to london on a
full-time basis and take his spot that's
going to accelerate whatever long-term
plan he may have for london so at some
point you're going to have these owners
begin to wake up to how much money they
can make there and if they can work
through the logistical aspects of it uh
we just have to be ready for it they've
talked about it for a long time and i
thought they're just dangling at carrot
to keep the people in london interested
they're never going to move a team there
yesterday was the first time i thought
holy crap they actually may move a team
to london well we we heard the raiders
complain right about all the travel they
had to do i just can't imagine a team
being able to pull it off and listen i'm
for it i want it to happen i'm just the
realistic part of my brain which is
small but yet it's still there is
telling me that's going to be tough and
you know the other thing i just think
about okay yeah you heard john gruden a
lot of press conferences oh we flew 97
000 miles this year and oh it was you
know ridiculous with man that is gonna
be stressful on a team two if there's
another team that if their team is in
london you know how do you work out the
playoffs to where that's fair too you
know oh hey you're you're you're the
team in london and you know you you're
okay you're playing a game over there
the last game of sunday night on wild
card weekend right and all of a sudden
now you got scheduled for a saturday
game and you were in london the day
before whatever it may be to me that's
not fair to those teams either when it
came to that time so those are the
logistics at least of me as a player in
my brain where i go man that would piss
me off if i was playing in the playoffs
and having to go to london and then
maybe go to the west coast the next
round six days later and be all messed
up in my brain you know my clock my body
clock and all those things
well
there's nothing like this that
that that mike all i can say is this you
think that that the 32 owners and roger
goodell and and the nfl when they're
thinking about london you think they're
thinking about man it's going to be
rough on the players no they're not
they're a playoff fee
[Laughter]
they're definitely not right hey hey and
that reminded me of when elaine
complained to david putty she was going
to hell and he said it's going to be
rough yeah it's going to be rough on you
not on me you're absolutely right one
last point though i was reminded while
we were talking of the story that jarvis
landry told of adam gase when he was the
coach of the dolphins threatening
players he'll trade you to cleveland
i'll tell you what you got a better you
got a better threat you can make now i'm
trading you to london baby and i
guarantee you there will be more no
trade clauses or specifically no trade
to london clauses that may be part of
the cba because the last thing you want
to have happen is get that phone call in
october you're going to london for the
rest of the season and maybe beyond
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports